now more of our teresa giudice exclusive
will she quit housewives to focus on her
family possibly moved there for girls to
Italy Brook asked Teresa point blank
about it all starting with her future
with Joe many people are curious
would you ever divorce Joe no we're
gonna be a family and and we're gonna
fight this and get through this on the
flip side if things don't go your way
throughout the appeals process is there
a scenario where you and the girls pick
up and you move out of the country with
Joe we're not even thinking about that
right now is it more important to keep
the whole family together in your mind
or to preserve your girls lives here
what comes first is our daughters and
and we're gonna fight this one thing
that Teresa will say definitively her
Real Housewives fame has not helped the
case I don't think my family would be
going through this if I wasn't in a
spotlight you feel like your life would
be totally different had you not done
this show in Joe's life not the show the
spotlight of being in the public eye
okay would you ever consider in the
future not doing it to be able to focus
even more at home and on the girls I am
focusing like 110 percent on my
daughters and this show is my job I'm
putting food on the table for them will
we see anything about this in this
season of Housewives no because we
weren't filming when this just happened
will you address it in future seasons I
can't predict the future
oh I'm telling listen you know what's
coming the spin-off show them in Italy
come on down I'm here
[Applause]